la atención en ucrania esta mañana sigue
en la ciudad de mariupol donde al menos
200 civiles y un número indeterminado de
militares siguen atrapados en esos
subterráneos de las heridas o estas que
están siendo atacados con insistencia
por las fuerzas rusas especialmente
desde ayer que comenzaron una nueva
ofensiva las partes que llegan desde los
militares que están al interior de estos
túneles dicen que sigue siendo un
infierno que los ataques no cesan y que
cada vez son mayores las naciones unidas
y la cruz roja han iniciado una nueva
misión de rescate de los civiles que
continúan allí atrapados ya esta semana
salieron al menos 150 personas que
llegaron hasta la ciudad de esa policía
donde ellos dicen que lo que se vive
allí es indescriptible repiten esas
palabras que repiten los militares que
esto es un infierno así que se espera
que estas personas puedan salir de allí
aunque las mujeres y las familias de los
militares hacen un llamado para recordar
que ellos también tienen que ser
evacuados del lugar muchos de ellos
están heridos así que esperan que en los
últimos días ellos puedan salir porque
el tiempo se agota mucho se cree que el
kremlin quiere anunciar el 9 de mayo ese
día en que yo celebra la victoria contra
la alemania nazi que son victoriosos en
mario poli y que tienen el control total
de este puerto sobre el mar de azov